[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
عايشي في المزرعه يطيب يعرفني بعيد وقريب
اعطيكم جبنا وحليب اهلا اهلا يا بقره اهلا
يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوت خوالك كي
نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل امت السنجاب دقه دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
ابيض يدفو جسمي صوف وبقتل العشب معروف هذا
انا احد الضيوف اهلا بك اهلا يا خروف اهلا
يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا اسمع مامتك كي نفتح
في الحال الباب
دائما في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
حسناء ولدي قرون ولدي الجد الا تدرون هل
عرفتم من اكون اهلا يا معزه اهلا اهلا يا
اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوت غائب كي نفتح
في الحال الباب ماء ماء في منزل انثى
السنجاب دقه دق الباب في منزل انثى
السنجاب دق دق الباب
من باب يكسوني ريش وافير لي جنحان ولا
اطير والسوسو ولدي الصغير اهلا يا دجاجه
اهلا اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع صوت
نقيقي كي نفتح في الحال الباب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق
دقا بالباب جسمي يهتز ويميل ريش يكسو جسم
جميل من قارئ عريض وطويل اهلا اهلا يا بطه
اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع بطبطتك كي
نفتح في الحال
دقه دق الباب في منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق
الباب
من بالباب شعري جميل ذيل طويل ولصيد
الفئران امين اخرج اتجول بالليل اهلا يا
قطه اهلا اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع
صوتا وان كي نفتح في الحال الباب
[موسيقى]
في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب اعرف بصديقي الانسان ايضا انا
اوفى حيوان افتحوا قد جئت الان اهلا يا
كلب و سهلا اهلا يا اغلى الاصحاب هيا نسمع
صوت نباح كي نفتح في الحال الباب
المنزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب